so I am in Canada right now but more on
that another time because before I was
here I was in New York there it is proof
New York right out the window I'm here
because I'm attending New York Fashion
Week because you know I'm a born
fashionista when you think Charlie's to
call like you think fashion don't you
think fashion basically Tommy Hilfiger
invited me to come to their New York
Fashion Week show and initially when
they asked me to come I thought I was
gonna say no because why would I do that
why I don't know anything about fashion
but then I thought well that's why you
do new things isn't it not because you
know you're gonna enjoy yourself but
because you haven't done them before and
you say you might not have a good time
so I'm here New York Fashion Week we're
gonna do it we're gonna see how it goes
I'm gonna give you my honest opinions on
the whole thing because I don't know how
else to do oh and Emily came with me too
because I couldn't go to Fashion Week
without taking the most fashionable
person I know with me could I grab our
way now to the big Tommy Hilfiger store
and they're gonna buy us some clothes
because emily is probably fashionable
enough for a fashion week I need some
saying - I think I was actually kind of
worried that being styled would involve
me being dressed up in lots of silly
clothes but I think the stylist must
have sensed my fear and so all of the
clothes were well within my comfort zone
ie everything was just a different shade
of blue I tried on a bunch of different
combos while proving between the outfits
that I don't exactly have much dexterity
when it comes to putting on clothes you
are the slowest dresser in the world but
ultimately I picked this outfit and then
I was ready to blend in with all of the
fancy fashion people at the Fashion Show
hello cool ok day to Fashion Show
Fashion Show that's happening tomorrow
so today behind the scenes now I think I
must have expected to see a bit more for
as much as behind the scenes of a
fashion show because while it was really
cool to see people putting together all
of their finishing touches it also just
seemed quite normal and relaxed back
there the most exciting thing going on
was probably watching a real-life model
take some fancy fashion photos which was
also the point where I discovered that
the theme of the show was American
football the model in question was Ian
eaves who I was also given the chance to
interview but I was so wholly unprepared
that my questions only ever got as
deepers so do you um do you like the
clothes which she responded that she
hadn't even seen them yet so very
in-depth reporting and then finally it
was day 3 and it was time for the
fashion show
why am i doing why did they give this
opportunity to me and not like a fashion
blogger or something this makes no sense
the runway itself which is the thing the
models walk down was kind of incredible
and nothing like I expected a runway to
look either because well it looked like
an actual football field with a
Jumbotron and everything that was a
brand new word for me by the way
Jumbotron
we were given a bit of backstage access
to which was much closer to what I
imagined backstage at a fashion show to
be very busy and loud with models
getting makeup tan hair getting twiddled
and a mirror that could connect to
Twitter obviously behind the scenes of
this very very busy
fashion is overwhelming then we watch
the rehearsal the finale of which was
actually kind of terrifying because it
felt like I was about to be attacked by
all of the models or something I was
gonna say it was loud in here thank you
for turning up the music then all of the
cool fashion people started to arrive
and none of them came up to tell me that
I wasn't supposed to be there so I guess
my disguise worked and then it was time
for the show and although I'd seen clips
of fashion shows many times before in
person I actually found the whole thing
quite difficult to process there were
just so many outfits and I didn't find I
had nearly enough time to look properly
at any of them I started to think about
just the sheer amount of work and effort
that must have gone into this whole
thing not just the spectacle but how
long each individual outfit must have
taken to make and then all of a sudden
the whole thing was over
after the show I didn't get a chance to
say hello to Tommy Hilfiger himself
which I kind of messed up by not saying
hello to him at all but he was a nice
man stand next to at least he smelled
great sand that was New York Fashion
Week the bit I got to see over anyway I
came into this whole thing feeling like
I never really liked I didn't really get
fashion and now I still don't entirely
understand it and yet I still found
myself kind of blown away by the whole
thing like just the scale of it like the
amount of people involved and the
attention to detail and just the the
showmanship of the thing I may not have
understood it all but it was still
easily one of the most impressive just
shows that I've ever been to and I still
feel very lucky and surprised that I got
to attend all so I'll say something
small ain't there right now I'm just
overwhelmed thank you very much for
coming on this little trip to New York
with me and hopefully I'll see you next
time goodbye you've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching Charlie is
so cool like which makes you like cool
thank you very much for watching if
you'd like to see him a previous video
you can find that to your left and if
you'd like to see more from the show you
can find that to your right thank you
very much to Anne Rowe from Tommy
Hilfiger for inviting me to go on this
trip that was very kind of you and also
probably quite brave because I know I'm
not the most obvious choice for this
sort of thing but I had a lot of fun and
I hope you did too and that's the end of
this voiceover bit goodbye